hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
Stanley parable now I'm going to follow
all of his directions
cuz I'm such a good little boy that
wasn't awkward at all
alright so anyway I'm just gonna skip
ahead of the initial dialogue since you
already know it if you haven't seen it
go back see my other video this is a
story of the man named Stanley Stanley
decided to go to the staff line agent
funnies [ __ ] absolutely he never
functioned well by himself you are
constantly needed supporting guidance
from others so the thought of total
solitude was terrifying when Stanley
came to a set of two open doors
[Music]
Stanley entered the lounge he was
horrified if I not a single person here
he decided he would walk up to see his
boss hoping that he would find an answer
there I think I'll go see my boss I hope
there's an answer there well that looks
complicated
oh two five one coming to a staircase
Stanley walked upstairs to his boss all
Carter's choices choices they are slit
early so many choices in this game sube
but Stanley just couldn't do it couldn't
I could consider the possibility of
facing his boss yes of admitting that he
had left his post during work house
could not be fired for that and in such
a competitive economy was it really
worth taking that risk yeah all because
he believed everyone had disappeared his
boss would think he was crazy and then
something occurred to Stanley yeah maybe
he thought to himself maybe I am crazy
everyone I know simply vanishing
the blue there's almost no other
explanation for it and a nagging fear
began to creep up in his mind questions
that had been there all along he just
hadn't put his finger on them yet for
example why couldn't I see his feet he
looked down no why did doors close
automatically behind him wherever he
went there are and for that matter these
rooms were starting to look pretty
familiar was he just walking around in
circles where am I he thought where am i
and the more he found himself unable to
answer these questions
the more questions continued to arise
until he came to the issue that have
been slowly balling until he could
ignore it no longer know why is there a
voice in my head hating everything that
I'm doing and thinking Oh suddenly every
door slammed shut no Stanley screamed I
need to get out of here I need to know
that there's something out there I need
to know it's not just all in my head and
he screamed I touched at his skull voice
grew harsher the musical background rose
higher and then moments before
collapsing to the ground then make
clenched his fists and screamed to
anyone who might be listening I'm not
real
I'm not real don't believe any of it
none of its real and then everything
went black
this is the story of a woman named
Mariela Mariela woke up on a day like
any other all right then she got dressed
went to work clocked in clocked out and
then she walked home okay but her walk
on this day was interrupted by the body
of a man who had stumbled through town
talking and screaming to himself and
then collapsed dead on the side that's
moments after seeing him she would turn
run to the nearest police station and
call for an ambulance but for just a few
brief seconds she merely stood there
unable to move the tragedy was not the
death of a single person it was that she
would never know this man's story never
here in his own words what had happened
to him or what he believed it happened
to him for to know these things would be
to exist inside the head of the man
himself so all she could do was observed
from a distance and pity him
but Mariela had places to be and people
to meet with very important people whose
impressions of her would affect her
career and indeed the rest of her time
for Stanley she stood there for only a
moment
looking down at the body and then she
ran
[Music]
that was awesome
and I didn't expect that was tip 1 be
that's why I love these experimental
games now
let's um let's not make the choice that
leads to instant death please the stairs
we go to the boss boss boss and Truths
manager's office
Stanley was once again stunned to
discover not an indication of any human
life it was at this point that he began
to feel dizzy and a little sick and even
thought he might pass out when suddenly
he noticed a keypad next to the filing
cabinet in the corner of his bosses all
Stanley had never seen this panel before
and had no idea what combination of
numbers would produce any result in fact
only Stanley's boss knew this since the
panel withheld access to the bosses
greatest darkest secret so he had
assigned the keypad a combination that
only he could possibly know a knife or
floppies freshmen dorm numbering Carl
one nine five seven okay but of course
Stanley couldn't possibly have known
this or could I have one what one one
nine of five yet incredibly by simply
pushing random bus Stanley happened to
by ship amazing Stanley ventured for a
newly opened passage when the door
opened up I like as he drew deeper into
the bowels of the building ship bells
family had no idea where he was or what
this place hazard people and just as he
began to think he might not discover a
thing he emerged into a long room to
find Oh realms and row row monitors
screens with a number above it I scream
Stanley noticed however that these were
not random numbers
but the number of employees who worked
in the building all his co-workers
mm-hmm
even his own number to Solon had a place
on the wall but why are setup so
elaborate Yost was this simple
surveillance or something even more and
as if in answer to his question all slid
open before him revealing the ultimate
truth of the situation say wha
okie-dokie an enormous control panels
standard discovered but not one the
controlled simple machinery buttons were
labeled with emotions happy sad leavers
and knobs controlled actions walking
eating doing work or watching TV every
input on this device monitored not the
functions of a machine but of a human
being a human machine and the reality
began to sink in Stanley like so many
other people reduced to images on a
monitor had been under someone's control
always at the mercy of this machine
could this have been the only reason
employee number 47 was content with his
boring job that a machine had altered
his emotions to accept it blindly things
like it he began to feel an unbridled
rage a spa Stanley looked up and saw the
generator overhead still providing some
small amount of power to the machine
keeping it alive okay and knowing that
this generator was all the kept the
controls running Stanley alerted the
ladder in the back of the washer tell
him to climb towards the rock okay
Hey look at your thing Hey look some
colors oh say who looks like another
choice I'm only gonna get to be able to
play so many choices here so you guys
definitely if you want to play the game
for yourself click a link in the
description below and download it this
is awesome I do I turned it red new
blackness black power gone and then as
he stepped through the door into the
fresh outside air a feeling of
liberation rushed through Stanley's body
he had seen power he had seen
enslavement oh ho and he had destroyed
the underling was in control now he had
found his leading role Stanley never
discovered why everyone had gone missing
nor how and when he had come under the
machines control but it didn't upset him
terribly because he knew that this was
how things were meant to happen all he
felt was a delight unlike any he had
ever known before
never again would he follow someone
else's orders without question oh never
again would anyone tell Stanley where to
go what to do or how to feel I think
I've got a flying horses no more
instructions on a screw
Stanley decides for himself I agree and
he stepped out into the world and he
felt the cool breeze upon his skin and
Stanley was happy is there something
else nope that was it man I just love
these games like this I mean I kind of
want to encourage you guys to shut off
the thing right now and just try it for
yourself because like things like this
imaginative games or what gaming is all
about but just because I know people
would ask for it I'm gonna do the other
one all these people I also like acting
like Stan
Oh Stan you didn't just activate the
controls well I sure did after it kept
you enslaved all these years you go and
you try to take control of the machine
feel self is that what you wanted
control Stanley Stanley I applaud you do
but you need to understand there's only
so much that machine can do you were
meant to let it go turn the controls off
and me if you want to throw my story off
track you're gonna have to do better
than that yeah I'm afraid you don't have
nearly the power you think you have for
example and I believe you'll find this
pertinent okay Stanley suddenly realized
that he had just initiated the network's
emergency detonations No in the event
that this machine is activated without
problem DNA identification nuclear
detonators are set to explode
eliminating the entire compost how long
until detonation then oh let's make it
say
two minutes per minute this is making
things a little more fun okay play with
those controls older Alec the real
controls are where I'm sitting
did you really ever believe you know any
bird did you not think I knew what I
would say when I erased your coworkers
and turned off the machine I was
offering you freedom and escape I didn't
have to run this story many times and I
don't always send you free sometimes you
just said day after day after day doing
your job forever what I actually give
you the freedom to control your own
actions not enough I let you go and you
trapped yourself just the same you just
weren't made to handle this sort of
responsibility Oh Fred what you were
made for
oh no pushing a button you get it now
now I'm enjoying all throws an extra
time on the clock just because I'm
having so much fun you're a douche there
we go you see I want to watch you for
every long second to try to puzzle this
out after all it should make sense right
the timer the nuclear detonation the
mysterious facility it's all here this
is a video game except for one thing
they're heroes you've got no weapon no
vehicle you don't even know where your
girl I do know when you saw that timer
you just instinctively started trying to
find an exit no bird resentence I bet
you're still looking from the window I
bet you're clicking on everything in
this new kind of indoors or vents or
something so the puzzle though this game
has a solution as though it can be won
that timer is not a catalyst to keep
things moving along
it's just seconds ticking away to your
death
this is not a challenge it's a tragedy
it's the moment when the hero realized
that despite his best efforts he is
powerless to his environment and then he
lets go out the door he surrenders he
dies thirty Seconds Stanley thirty
seconds until a boom no ending the story
is do die I suppose you could have
gotten a natural ending if you played
along that just wouldn't have been your
style
instead y'all perish knowing that the
only choice you made here was the turn
on that machine and to start this timer
or do you won't be alone because I'm not
going anywhere over I'll be here to
watch every second of your inevitable
life from the time we fade him until the
moment I say happily ever right then
oops oops oops I bet there was a pattern
that I was supposed to hit those lights
in but I couldn't figure it out anyway
I'm all that it's time so I challenge
you guys to figure it out for yourself
this is where you guys come in I want
you guys to play the game because it's
really something you should experience
for yourself I'll play it obviously baby
maybe I'll maybe I'll play it and record
it but for now that's gonna have to end
it here so thank you all so much for
watching click the link in the
description below to get the download
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye